FRED SAUER: Welcome everyone.
It's great to have you
here at the end of the day.
Thank you for sticking around.
We've seen some pretty
exciting announcements today.
I want to welcome
back to the stage
Urs Holzle, who is,
as you already know,
the senior VP in charge of
technical infrastructure
at Google responsible for
building all the data centers.
I also want to welcome
Jeff Dean on stage.
Many of you know Jeff, and if
you don't, you probably should.
He is a senior Google
fellow and has had his hands
in every piece of major
infrastructure at Google,
and he's built
many of the systems
that you know and have heard
about that have inspired
many open source projects
such as MapReduce, BigTable,
Spanner.
He's worked on web search, the
ad serving system, basically
all the important
bits at Google.
So Urs, if I can
start with you, maybe
ask you a couple questions that
are on top of developers minds
today.
We've heard a lot
about the commitment
to Cloud and
everything that Google
is putting behind the
Google Cloud Platform.
Could you maybe
tell us a little bit
about why Cloud is important to
Google, why Cloud is important
you.
URS HOLZLE: Sure.
So it's really two
things coming together.
One is that we always like
to think about the long term.
If you think about it
in a 10 year time frame,
there isn't really any
chance that 10 years from now
the public Cloud isn't a
major, major part of the world.
Today, everyone talks about it.
But the reality is that
you all who are using Cloud
are part of the vast minority
of developers and IT folks
who actually are doing it.
But if you think 10 years
out, there's just no question
that a reasonable fraction of
the world's server side cycles
are going to be in
the public Cloud.
And that's going to be an
interesting business for us,
for others too, and so if
you look at just the numbers
it's easily bigger than the
advertising business is for us.
So that's the business
opportunity side.
Then the second part is
the technical opportunity.
We've been living at Google
in the Cloud for 15 years
basically.
For 13 of these 15 years our
Cloud was just for our own use.
But we've learned a lot,
and many of the things we've
learned apply directly
to the public Cloud.
And you mention Jeff, we
came up with MapReduce,
and that's now turned
into a very common thing
that everyone uses.
It's just that we had
the problems earlier,
and that's why we came
across there early.
So there's a big
opportunity for us
to actually take that
technical leadership
and really turn it
into product leadership
on the external side,
just not the internal one.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Yesterday there was an article
in "Wired Magazine" where
you were quite prominently
featured, and in that article
there was a memo
that was described
that you wrote to folks
in your organization,
to the technical
infrastructure team,
but also to the rest of
Google, and you set a call
to change the
direction in motion.
Could you talk about
what you wrote,
and what was the reason
for sending this memo?
URS HOLZLE: Sure.
Engineers get to write code,
and managers get to write memos.
So we compete on equal footing.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF DEAN: How many lines of
memos have you done this year?
URS HOLZLE: That's right.
My memo's are very concise, and
I write them in [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
I write them in Google
Docs, of course.
We're really going
through a change.
So we started,
about two years ago,
to redo our internal
infrastructure
because in the 15 years
that we'd been doing it
we learned a lot and we
went through a big push
to simplify things.
We accumulated a lot
of stuff because we
tried a lot of things.
Some of them worked
and some of them
didn't, and now we
think we actually
know pretty well how to do that.
We're using this
infrastructure to power Cloud,
and we want those
two to be the same.
Previously, the last two years,
was really the preparation
for that, laying the groundwork.
And now that the platform
Compute Engine is actually
live, no longer
beta, now it's time
to really move many more of
our infrastructure systems
onto the external platforms.
So the new world
memo that I wrote
was really about
taking this year
and making this the number
one priority for everyone,
and have a majority
of the organization
work on the external product
rather than the internal one.
And one of the
reasons we can do that
is because our internal one is
actually in pretty good shape.
So not working quite as much on
it is not going to hurt anyone.
So this year we're really
spending the majority
of our effort in externalizing
the many things that we haven't
externalized yet, because
the platform now is ready.
And so adding people will
actually make things go faster
rather than slower.
FRED SAUER: So it's a
pretty significant shift.
URS HOLZLE: Yeah, definitely.
FRED SAUER: Hence the memo.
URS HOLZLE: Yeah.
Yes.
FRED SAUER: So, App Engine,
in less than two weeks time,
turns six.
So Google has been
working on the Cloud
platform for quite some time.
But it seems that,
not only seems,
but there is actual
accelerated lunches
that have been happening in the
last 12 months, and of course
with today's event.
Was delivering and creating
the Google Cloud Platform
always the plan for
you from day one,
or is this something that
has evolved over time?
URS HOLZLE: So I
think the dichotomy
between infrastructure
as a service and platform
as a service is really
a false dichotomy.
It's really much more of a grey
scale, and you saw that today.
We want to make it a grey scale
where you can be all the way
over here where we make all the
choices for you and your life
is really, really easy, or over
here where you can make all
the choices and
your life is really,
really flexible but maybe you
have to do a little bit more
work.
And there aren't
just these two points
but there's is basically
anything in between.
So I think what we realized was
that even though people were
extremely successful
on App Engine,
you heard Snapchat today, but
there's many other examples.
People really love App Engine
because they can walk away
from an application
after they deployed it.
Really the way we say, you're
only maintenance action
for years is to renew
your credit card.
That's really all
you have to do.
And there's incredible
value in that.
But even the biggest users
of App Engine said, hey look,
I have this other piece
on here and it's not
realistic to rewrite it, or
I don't want to rewrite it,
or it's actually
great as it is, and I
need be able to just run it.
And for that you need VMs so
they can wrap them around.
And our goal really
is to say, look,
pick the parts
that you like most,
implement the components
the way you see fit,
and then fit things
together into a low effort,
high performance, easy
to maintain system.
So it's really not an either/or.
So that's that.
We set out, certainly,
with a vision
of having something that's very
high level, very easy to use,
and very low touch once
you're done, very productive.
Actually, if you
ask me to bet, I
would say, 10 years
from now, that
is going to be the main way of
how you actually use a Cloud.
Because if you can fit into
that pattern, it's so useful,
it's so low cost because you
don't have to touch anything,
that that's really a big win.
But you've got to cover
the entire spectrum,
and there's a lot between
now one and 10 years from now
that's going to change.
It's an iffy bet
even for me to make.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So when you run and manage the
world's largest data centers
and you're hosting
millions of applications
and that application
data, security
has to be just at
the top of your mind.
Why should developers trust
their data to the cloud?
URS HOLZLE: So I think
there's two answers.
One is we're probably going to
do a better job than you would
do yourself, because
security is hard
and there's always all
kinds of ways to screw up
and we have a great team.
The second one is
that there used
to be this conception that
IT needs security, that's
where your standards
are high, and consumers,
they will deal with
something that's insecure.
But that's not really true.
With consumers having moved
much more of their personal data
into the Cloud, they set
the very high standards,
they have very
high expectations.
So for us, as a
consumer Cloud provider,
a security incident would
be extremely expensive.
So we're actually spending
hundreds of people on security,
we have a very
good security team,
to really try and make
that extremely unlikely.
And even on the
consumer side you
have security features
like one time passwords
that are ahead of many
enterprise products today.
Or our HTTPS for years now
has used elliptic curve
cryptography, which
makes it much, much more
secure against intruders.
Even if you get the
master key at some point,
you still cannot decrypt
recorded sessions.
So we've worked
really hard on that,
and I think if you look
at this as a developer do
you want to take
advantage of that,
or do you want to
try your own luck?
I think you're going to be
better off doing it this way.
In the Cloud we have the extra
advantage that if you wish,
you can go encrypt your
data with your own key
where not even we
have access to it.
So you get the
infrastructure that's
already very secure against
the common mistakes,
and then on top of that you
have your own extra layer
of security under control.
So that's really a
pretty good place,
versus hosting yourself
is really, I think,
a bad proposition.
FRED SAUER: So you could get the
best of both worlds that way.
URS HOLZLE: Exactly.
You can layer on top.
You can bring your own security.
But you really benefit
from all the work
that we've already done.
In the long term people
ask what about security
in the Cloud,
compliance in the Cloud?
That's just as much of the
success as technical features.
So if the Cloud really is 10
years from now a major factor
in everything IT,
then very clearly it
needs to be the best security
place, and the best compliance
place, just as it is the best
technical place and the best
economical place.
These things need
to come together.
You can't really leave them out.
So almost by
definition our security
will be very good,
because it has to be.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So I'd like to move in a little
bit to innovation at scale.
And Jeff, since
we have you here,
you've been involved in all the
large scale distributed systems
at Google.
I wonder if you could share
some of the challenges you've
witnessed, and had to deal with,
and program around that really
only happen at that
very large scale.
Things that you
wouldn't see if you
have an isle of servers
in a data center,
but something you
see when you have
data centers full of
computers, warehouse scale
machines, many data
centers across the world,
50 years of running
software on there.
JEFF DEAN: Battle scars.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
Show us your battle scars.
JEFF DEAN: I think
there's a lot of lessons
we've learned over time.
From the very early
days of Google
we had hardware that was
very consumer oriented
hardware, didn't have a lot
of reliability features built
into the hardware that you
might, like ECC memory,
or even parody for
our earliest machines.
So if you sort a terabyte of
memory, a terabyte of data,
with a machine
that's on parody, it
ends up mostly sorted,
and sorted again.
It's mostly sorted
some other way.
So I think from
those early days,
to work around that, we built a
software check summing library
that is in constant use in old
pieces of our infrastructure,
just to make things more
robust for that very low level
hardware.
Modern machines have ECC errors,
but sometimes switch buffers
don't necessarily have
ECC so you get corruption,
even in never transit.
So these kinds of
things are really
good for protecting
against that.
I think when you're pushing
the boundaries of scale,
like you're running systems that
are 1,000s or perhaps 10,000s
of machines, you see failure
modes that are really rare
but are very perplexing
and annoying that you
wouldn't necessarily see if
you're running 100 machine
systems.
A good example is if a
whole rack switch goes bad.
That's a pretty rare event,
but all of a sudden you
lose 40 machines, or 80
machines off your network.
But even more nasty
than that is a switch
that is kind of working.
So it drops half the
packets coming through it.
URS HOLZLE: Only
in one direction.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
Or only in one direction.
That's actually tricky because
things like health checking
and so on, that are designed
to see if something's alive,
actually work.
It is alive.
It's just incredibly slow
and you can't actually
communicate effectively
with other machines.
So these are the
kinds of problems
that you see running at scale.
One of the things
that has happened
is you recognize these
sorts of problems,
and then you build
infrastructure to, in software,
deal with these kinds of
failures automatically.
So some of the things that
we built into MapReduce
are designed to be robust to
not just a particular kind
of failure, but lots
of kinds of failures.
Even ones we can't imagine
right now because the software
techniques are just effective at
dealing with when things aren't
working right, no
matter how exactly they
aren't working right.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So Urs, you co-authored a book.
It's called "Data
Center as a Computer.
An Introduction to the Design
of Warehouse-Scale Machines."
In there you talk about
this software tolerance.
If we get the point where we can
design some of our own hardware
and build better
switches, tell us
why we can't just
build better hardware
so Jeff doesn't have
to work so hard.
URS HOLZLE: We can and
we do, but Jeff still
has to work hard.
[LAUGHTER]
The problem is that
scale, in the end,
gets you even if
you try to avoid it.
Even if you had an incredibly
good piece of hardware,
there's no manufacturer
in the world that
can make 100,000
of them and have
them work three years
without things failing.
So once you accept that
you will have failure
as part of the every day,
then whether something fails
three times more often or not
is actually not your problem.
The problem is that
there are failures
that you have to recognize,
and isolate, and automatically
deal with.
I think we came to peace
with that a long time ago.
Because you really realize, OK,
even if I could do it better
by a factor of 10, and I don't
see any vendor who does it
better by a factor of
10, but even if I did it,
basically my software
effort is still the same
because failures
would still happen.
And to some extent the
more frequent failures
are the ones that
you handle really
well because those are
the really well tested
kinds of things.
So to some extent,
there really is not
an advantage in
making them more rare.
So generally we pick
the right point,
so today we do have ECC memory
because memory errors actually
are, in today's
lithography, are even more
common than they used to be.
So we absolutely
want to have it.
But still, do we actually have
memory errors that even ECC two
bit ECC correction,
does not detect?
The answer is yes.
At scale you're going to see.
I haven't done the
computation recently,
but I'm sure we see it at least
every week, probably every day,
just based on the amount
of RAM that we do have.
JEFF DEAN: It's coordinated
with the solar flares.
URS HOLZLE: Exactly right.
Alpha ray, Alpha particles,
and so on and so on.
You have to go deal with it,
and have enough resilience
so that you can
actually still move on.
FRED SAUER: So the way I
read this and summarize
it is being on the Cloud
platform insulates me
from solar flares.
JEFF DEAN: Among other things.
FRED SAUER: Among other things.
URS HOLZLE: Hopefully yes.
Yes.
Hopefully yes.
We really hope that we can
expose some of these things
that we learned as tools
that make it easier for all
of you to build applications,
and not actually have
to understand how to deal with
failure because as long as you
follow these simple
rules, you will be fine.
That's the ideal situation.
Today we have realized
that in App Engine,
and on the VM side
to a smaller extent,
we've realized it
with the VM migration
where we're able to move you
away from something that we see
coming, and you don't know
that this even happened,
but we can do a lot
more in that area.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So Jeff, when you were
building the first iterations
of these distributed systems
14 and 1/2 years ago,
did you realize when you were
trying to make the engineering
trade offs in dealing
with failures,
providing availability for
systems, and consistency,
did you realize at the time that
it was essentially those three
components, the cap theorem,
consistency, availability,
and partitioning,
that we're really
underlying the
engineering decisions?
URS HOLZLE: Just to
interrupt, I think
it's called Brewer's theorem.
At least that's how
I like to call it.
JEFF DEAN: Really?
I always call it
the cap theorem.
URS HOLZLE: No, its
Brewer's theorem.
ERIC BREWER: I think
I know this one.
URS HOLZLE: I think
you're thinking
too much about cats I think.
JEFF DEAN: No, cap.
ERIC BREWER: I think
I know this one.
JEFF DEAN: All right.
ERIC BREWER: May I join you?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
Please.
URS HOLZLE: Everyone
please welcome Eric Brewer.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF DEAN: What a surprise.
ERIC BREWER: Good
to see you again.
FRED SAUER: Eric, thank
you for joining us.
ERIC BREWER: My pleasure.
FRED SAUER: So you noticed that
we had the three person couch,
so obviously we
needed a third guest.
ERIC BREWER: Saw that coming.
FRED SAUER: So if
you don't know Eric,
he devised the cap theorem,
or Brewer's theorem,
we'll let him answer that
question in a moment.
He's a professor at UC
Berkeley of computer science.
A pioneer really in building
large scale systems,
built the first really useful
cluster for web infrastructure.
And can you tell
us, do you prefer
cap theorem or Brewer's theorem.
ERIC BREWER: Actually
I prefer cap theorem
because it sounds
bad coming from me
to call it Brewer's theorem.
URS HOLZLE: OK.
ERIC BREWER: You can call
it whatever you like,
but I'm always going
to call it cap theorem.
URS HOLZLE: I'll cal
it Brewer's theorem.
ERIC BREWER: That's all right.
I don't mind.
FRED SAUER: Can
you maybe tell us
a little bit about cap theorem?
I think sometimes it's
explained incorrectly as a two
our of three choice.
ERIC BREWER: Well,
I think in 2000,
or really when I first
thought about it, it was 1998,
it was a two out of
three choice in the sense
that we were in an era where
everyone wanted ACID properties
and wanted us to
build, literally,
cross national systems
that had both availability
and consistency.
I realized that we weren't
going to be able to do it,
but also that we were
regularly choosing
availability over consistency.
People didn't accept that
that was the choice that I
had to make, so
they were actually
very reticent to say
that's an OK choice.
So cap theorem, in some
sense, was to give everyone,
myself included, permission
to choose availability.
And now that's what happened.
People like Jeff chose
availability for BigTable,
and many others have as well.
I think it's because
the internet is
the first time we've
had a 24 by 7 service,
except maybe the phone system
which isn't really data system,
it's a communications
system, where you actually
had both data and availability
that you wanted to get.
So we had to start making
some difficult choices, which
we still make actually.
FRED SAUER: So in
addition to cap theorem,
you've also looked at the
origins of a SQL and NoSQL
databases.
And on the Cloud platform you
can get a Managed SQL service,
managed NoSQL service, but
you can also run your own.
If you do VMs you
can spin up Cassandra
and you have your own flavor
of a large NoSQL system.
How should developers think
about those trade offs
and how they select
one over the other?
ERIC BREWER: I actually
try not to choose.
I just told you,
you have to choose.
You only have to
choose if you are
going to have our
partitions, and only
during the small amount of
time where you have partitions.
The rest of the time
you can actually
mix them much more gracefully.
I would say we've
already built systems,
and certainly talked
about some, like Spanner
that Jeff worked on,
where you can set it
in a more consistent setting
or more of an availability
setting, and you can
make those choices
on a relatively fine grain.
If you know you want
partitions, like you're
doing mobile phones or
disconnected operations
and you really are going to
have truly concurrent operations
on both sides of
partitions, then you really
have to plan around that and
think about your merging.
Otherwise, I think you can be
a bit more graceful about it.
At least that's
the modern answer.
FRED SAUER: So you can have
all three legs of the stool,
but just not all at the
same time all the time.
ERIC BREWER: You have
to play with them a bit
more gracefully.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So Jeff, if you've been
building many generations
of these storage
systems, maybe you
can talk about the
problems you were working
on when you developed
BigTable and MapReduce.
What were the fundamental
big data problems?
JEFF DEAN: So
MapReduce originated
when my colleague
Sanjay Ghemawat
and I were working on
rewriting the core indexing
system for web search at Google.
The pipeline, at that
time, goes from a bunch
of raw pages on disk that
our crawler has collected,
sitting in a bunch of files.
And you have a
bunch of stages that
are trying to transform
it and do things
like find duplicates and choose
which one of the duplicates
you want to because
it has a prettier URL,
compute page rank,
decide which pages
we're going to put in the index,
what languages they're all in.
So there's all
these little phases
that, conceptually, are
doing pretty simple things.
But the code had gotten
really complicated
because in each of those phases,
we rolled our own parallelism
for the that phase.
We'd say, well, this
one runs pretty fast
so we need to use a
couple hundred machines.
This one's slow so 1,000
machines would be better.
Each one of them
had its own check
pointing mechanism
and recovery mechanism
for that to deal with failures.
Because when you're running
on that many machines,
you have failures.
And so what got lost in
there was actually the fact
that all these operations
were relatively
simple and
straightforward, and they
were obscured by all
this nasty support code.
So Sanjay started squinting
at each of the phases looking
for abstractions that
we felt could represent
all the simple computation
we were trying to do in a way
that we could then hide all
the complexity of dealing
with failures, and
automatically parallelizing
across an appropriate
number of machines,
and dealing with slow
machines in a library.
So MapReduce is what
we came up with.
We both have
backgrounds in looking
at different
programming languages,
and the functional
programming paradigm
is a pretty useful one.
So MapReduce builds, at
least loosely, on that.
So we realized that all the
phases in the indexing system
could be represented
in this abstraction,
and then we could work hard on
making that one library perform
really well.
So that's the
origin of MapReduce.
The origin of BigTable is
similar in that we wanted
to have an incrementally
updating system
for all of our indexing systems.
We wanted to have a row of data
for every page we know about
and then have
different columns that
are being
asynchronously updated.
So the crawler would go off
and fetch contents and then
write the actual current
contents into one of the cells,
and then there would
be other asynchronous
processes updating things
like what language we thing
that page is, all the
different phases we use
to run in a pipeline would
now run asynchronously,
then we'd always have the
current state of this page
by just looking at that route.
We needed to scale that out to
a very large number of machines
to be able to deal
with all the pages
that we wanted to represent.
FRED SAUER: OK.
And then how did that
lead then to Spanner?
What subsequent
problems were you
solving that BigTable
didn't address?
JEFF DEAN: So the first
version of BigTable
essentially ran
within one cluster,
within a single data center.
And then over time
we added some support
for eventual consistency to
have more interactive services
where you wanted to keep a bunch
of geographically distributed
versions of the data in sync.
But that was
somewhat unsatisfying
because you actually want all of
the things that you mentioned.
You want consistency
and availability.
it's actually a
pain for developers
to deal with having 12
BigTable replicas of their data
scattered around the world.
So what's Spanner solves
that BigTable didn't really
do is the problem of
geographic distribution of data
across wide areas,
potentially, and also
some flexibility in
allowing users to say,
well this particular data I want
to keep two copies in Europe
and three in the US
and I don't really
care where I keep them, that's
just roughly where I want them.
That gives the
underlying system freedom
to move data around in response
to changing patterns of demand,
and load, and disk availability
in our European data centers.
And also, Spanner allows
users of the system
to select the appropriate
consistency trade offs.
For some operations you want
a strongly consistent view
and you may pay for
it in availability.
Other ones, if I
marketing an email message
read or something, it's probably
fine to have an inconsistent
view of that data.
What's the worst
that could happen.
So I think allowing
users to pick that trade
off appropriately for
the different pieces
of their application is one
important thing Spanner allows
you to do.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So Eric, you joined Google
about two and 1/2 years ago?
ERIC BREWER: Yes.
FRED SAUER: And you're currently
on sabbatical from UC Berkeley,
and you've had a chance
to look at innovation
in the academic setting,
the commercial setting,
and you've seen it
firsthand inside of Google.
How would you compare the
way innovation happens?
Is the pace different?
What does it feel like
to be inside of Google
and how does it compare?
ERIC BREWER: Well when I
started in this area, which
is almost 20 years ago, we had
a cluster of four machines,
you could put it on a
disk, and that was actually
enough to make progress
on cluster computing.
You could actually
solve problems
that were new with
four machines.
And now we're at the
state where you really
need many, many, many, many,
many more machines than that.
So I feel like
Google is the place
to be to have the problems
that I want to solve.
They just aren't anywhere
else because of the scale,
and because really of the goals.
It's an ambitious
place to be and I
think I get a lot
of challenge out
of that and great enjoyment.
FRED SAUER: Is the
pace different?
Of Innovation, is
it faster at Google?
ERIC BREWER: Yeah.
I mean, it's faster
in several dimensions.
It's faster because you
have vastly more people.
It's also faster because
there is an urgency.
There's not much urgency
to Cloud computing in 1995.
I remember we went
from 10 machines
100, that was a big deal.
Like woo.
100 machines.
JEFF DEAN: It's a factor of 10.
ERIC BREWER: Yeah.
It was a factor of 10 and things
broke, and we had to fix stuff.
But it's definitely not the
breadth of stuff going on,
and also not really
the same ambition.
The time is more ambitious now,
and that's great for everybody.
FRED SAUER: So it's the harder
problems bigger scale really
that drives this.
ERIC BREWER: Absolutely.
URS HOLZLE: And actually
Fred, if I can add.
Having been in
academia myself, I
think one of the big
differences really,
that today I think
academia struggles with,
is that you may have the ideas,
but you don't have a good way
to test them.
And not just because you
lack the infrastructure,
but you also need real
world applications
to actually your thesis--
ERIC BREWER: You
need users and data.
URS HOLZLE: --whether
it really works.
One of the great
things at Google
is we're in a pretty good
place already because we've
been working on it for
10 years, so the standard
is relatively high.
We have great people and we
have great problems to solve,
and together that really
get's an acceleration factor.
My favorite quote
from the last half
year or so-- for those of
you, just a short digression
into networking.
Van Jacobson, maybe you know.
If you know TCP, you
know Van Jacobson.
He's at Google, he joined
us last spring or so.
I talked to him in the
summer and he said, you know,
I didn't expect it, but
in the last four months
I've gotten more done than I
have in the past five years.
And I said why.
And the answer was, I can
actually test an idea,
and I can test it very quickly,
and then the next day I
know I was wrong, but
I have a better idea.
So I can actually--
[LAUGHTER]
And before this took me
years to get to that point.
And that's one of the
big opportunities I have.
That's why I said before,
10 years from now we're not
going to live in the same world.
Things will profoundly
change because we
can discover along the way
the things that we do right,
and the things we do wrong, and
then think of better ways to,
or more innovative
ways to do them wrong.
But over time we get
them less and less wrong.
FRED SAUER: Talking about
that pace of innovation
in the future.
I see Jeff, you wore
your Google Brain shirt.
JEFF DEAN: My cerebellum
is folded though.
ERIC BREWER: It's
supposed to be folded.
FRED SAUER: I wanted
to ask about that.
You wrote a blog post,
I think it was 2012,
and you described what I'll just
call a very large cat detector.
But there's a lot
more behind it.
I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about the project,
what you did in 2012,
and then maybe we
can talk a little bit about
what's happened since then
and what the benefits to other
Google products have been.
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
The last couple years I've
been working on-- I've
switched gears a
little and have started
to look into very large scale
machine learning systems.
And in particular, systems
for framing very large neural
nets and then using them
for a variety of problems.
This project started because
Andrew Ng is a Stanford faculty
member with expertise in this
field of machine learning
and was spending a couple
days a week at Google,
and he and I bumped into
each other in a kitchen.
And he said, oh
yeah, I'm thinking
of figuring out how to use
neural nets for things.
And I said, oh, that
sounds like fun.
I'd actually done
a undergrad thesis
on parallel training of
[INAUDIBLE], a very long time
ago actually.
So he said, at small scales,
these kinds of approaches
were showing pretty promising
results in perceptual tasks.
Things like computer vision
and speech recognition.
So I said, wow.
That sounds like if we
just made them bigger,
they'd get even better.
So he and I and a
few other people
started a form a little
project around this
of how are we able-- can
we build systems that
allow us to train very large
neural networks to accomplish
interesting things.
So one of the first experiments
we did was what's called
unsupervised learning, where
you don't have the desired
output of the model, you
just have a bunch of raw data
and you want the
model to capture
regularities and interesting
patterns that it observes.
So the we did was
we took 10 million
YouTube videos, one of the
benefits of having lots of data
lying around, and we took one
frame from each one of them,
so it's a random
sampling of video frames,
and we put it through a model
where we essentially just tried
to learn representations that
were good at reconstructing
what the individual images were.
The training was
done on 16,000 cores,
and that's one of the
benefits of having
these large scale
cloud platforms.
That we can do those experiments
and get results more quickly.
So getting back to Van's
point of being able to get
results on your
experiment to figure out
what the next thing is
that you want to do.
Being able to run that on
16,000 cores instead of 1,000
is not necessarily as efficient
as doing it on 1,000 in terms
of actual dollars, but it
lets us get our results
more quickly so
we're more effect.
Anyway, we trained this model
in a completely unsupervised
manner, and then
we looked around
at what the highest layers
in this model-- so it's
like a deep, 10
layer neural net.
At the lowest layer,
the neurons learned
to be responsive to very
primitive things like edges
at different orientations.
And then as you
go up, the neurons
get a little more complicated.
So they'll learn corners
or things like that.
As you get a little
further up you'll
get pieces of chair legs
and things like that.
So we looked at the top layer,
at the very top of this model,
there are 60,000 neurons, and
then we had a test data set.
It's YouTube, so we said,
there's got to be cats.
So we took a test data set that
was half cats and half not,
and we knew those,
and we looked around
for a neuron that was most
sensitive to whether or not
the image contained a cat.
And if you can just skip ahead.
So we looked, and
we found a neuron
that was actually
pretty responsive.
These were the images that
caused that particular neuron
to get the most excited.
And you see they're mostly cats.
There's one Starbucks mug
there, but mostly cats.
If you can see this, this is
actually the representation
of the optimal
stimulus, the thing that
would cause that neuron
to get the most excited.
That's actually a cat.
It's pretty cool.
We call it average cat.
ERIC BREWER: It
was the house cat.
JEFF DEAN: By just
training on a lot of data,
this model has essentially
invented the concept of a cat
without ever being
told what a cat is.
I think that's a pretty
fundamental thing.
We looked around
at other neurons
and found one that was receptive
to faces, and backs of people,
and concepts that you
would expect these models
represent from just looking
at a whole bunch images.
FRED SAUER: I think
we have another slide.
Let's look at this
next one here.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
Then we shifted gears
a bit and realized
that, although this unsupervised
learning was incredibly cool,
there's actually
more applied uses you
can make if you have a
large, supervised data set.
So you have a bunch of images
and you have a bunch of labels,
so an image of a cheetah
and the label is cheetah,
and a garbage truck,
garbage truck.
If you can directly train
on that objective, where
you want to give it an image
and then have it tell you
what it is, supervised training
is actually pretty effective.
Again, once we've done a little
bit of supervised training,
we then looked at what
are the optimal stimuli
for a few of the neurons at
the top layer of this model,
and you see that some of them
are pretty good at succinctly
finding things that we would,
as humans, know what they are.
Like yellow flowers,
or wine bottles,
or balsamic vinegar,
or pizza at the bottom.
Some are a little more abstract,
they aren't a single succinct
category, but they are things
like very textured, spotty
objects.
I think that's an
indication of what's
going on in these models.
It's interesting.
FRED SAUER: So 16,000 cores,
probably 1,000 machines or so.
JEFF DEAN: Yep.
FRED SAUER: To detect a cat.
So how many cores would
we need to represent
the brain of a cat.
JEFF DEAN: Well, I think those
kinds of comparisons are hard.
I think have a
pretty good handle
on how to do training
for categorization tasks,
but the brain of a cat
is much more complex
and has a lot of mechanisms that
we don't understand quite as
well from a machine
learning standpoint,
how to do feedback and control.
But from a perceptual
view point,
I think we're getting
a handle on how
to train interesting systems
to do perceptual tasks pretty
well.
FRED SAUER: OK.
JEFF DEAN: We actually
have a fair number
of those perceptual
tasks at Google.
Some of them are very general
things like this general object
recognition, and some
are more fine grain.
So the street view team, if you
can click to the next thing,
wanted to be able to find text
in arbitrary street scenes.
So with a little
bit of label data
we had some people
draw bounding boxes
around text in some scenes.
You can actually see that this
model does a pretty good job
of finding text in these scenes,
which is the precursor to them
doing OCR of the world.
I have one more example there,
it's just another street scene.
But it's a pretty
challenging problem
because you see there's all
kinds of things like logos,
and different font
sizes, different fonts,
different colors.
But this model is actually able
to do this very effectively,
and is doing it from raw pixels.
You just feed in
raw images and it
is able to give
you this nice heat
map of where this text might be.
We have other models that find
street signs or other kinds
of interesting things
in these instances.
FRED SAUER: Have there been
benefits to other Google
projects from Google Brain?
You mentioned voice recognition.
Is that being used?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
So we've been
working with a whole,
growing array of
different teams.
We've had some very initial
close collaborations
with different teams.
So the speech team
was definitely
one of those early clients
we worked closely with,
to use our distributed training
system for problems they had.
In particular, they
wanted to build and train
very effective acoustic
models for speech recognition.
So that's the first part
of speech recognition
where you go from a
quarter second of raw wave
forms of speech, to predicting
what is the sound being uttered
in the middle 10 milliseconds.
Is it a "buh" or a "fl" or
a "ss," that kind of thing.
And then you stitch it
together with a language model
to actually figure out
what the utterance is.
Working with them we
were able to train
a pretty big acoustic model
that was actually much more
effective than the
previous kind of model
they were using for this.
And the word error rate
for English recognition
dropped by 30%.
FRED SAUER: Wow.
JEFF DEAN: Which is
a really huge drop.
ERIC BREWER: Unprecedented drop.
JEFF DEAN: This is unheard of.
Yeah.
And a 30% drop goes
from not quite usable
to actually quite usable
for a variety of tasks.
We're continuing
to push on making
the models bigger and better.
Then a whole bunch
of other teams
came to us after
they saw that success
on speech and on some
of the image tasks.
Now we have about 30 or 40
teams within Google applying
these models to all kinds
of different problems.
FRED SAUER: So the
neural networks
that you've been working
with, the basic form thereof
that they've been around
since the '80s, why is it
that we're making progress now?
JEFF DEAN: A few things.
One is, as you said,
the basic ideas
have been around
for about 20 years.
20 years ago, there wasn't
enough computational power
to train very large, and in
particular, very deep networks.
So people were playing
around with neural nets that
had maybe two or three
layers of abstraction
in them, and on fairly
small data sets.
So I think the big
difference is we now
have enough computational
power, and big enough data sets,
to really train
very large models
and have enough computational
power that we can do that
in a reasonable amount of time.
We have what we call a patience
threshold of four or five days
we're willing to wait
for a model train
completely from scratch, and
maybe a day if we're really
experimenting quickly.
The reason we use lots
and lots of machines
is because we want to train
the biggest model we possibly
can in that patience threshold.
FRED SAUER: OK.
JEFF DEAN: And if we're able to
train a bigger model because we
can parallelize things better,
or use machines, that's
just gravy because we can then
train more effective models
on larger data sets and so on.
FRED SAUER: I'd
like to step it back
into the data center world.
So we've just talked about this
neural network, 16,000 cores.
, That in Google scale is
probably a small scale system.
When we talk to lower
level storage systems,
they're much larger.
How does your technical
infrastructure
team deliver the network so
that all these machines can talk
together, both globally
and within the data center?
URS HOLZLE: Yeah.
It's definitely an
interesting problem.
And one of the nice
things is that it's
kind of like having a child.
It doesn't come with a
manual, but fortunately they
grow up slowly so
you have some time
to catch up with their demands.
And that's been us with
networking, or compute,
or storage.
If we had the
problem from day one,
then we would have been
pretty overwhelmed.
So networking is
actually something
that's become very important
in the last 10 or so years,
and we've started
to do a lot of work
because we got to the place,
just like with compute
or with software systems, we
couldn't buy what we needed.
There wasn't really a vendor.
So it wasn't a question
of should we build or buy
because which one is cheaper,
but really there is nothing out
there that you can buy so you
have to actually build it.
So one of the biggest
leaps we made recently,
is to convert our-- Actually,
let me back up for one second.
So we started building
networks obviously,
both inside the cluster and
between all the data centers.
So we've been owning Dark Fiber
and lighting our own optics
et cetera for a long time
because at that scale you need
to do that, both for
capacity and price reasons.
But one of the biggest
steps that we made recently
was to convert much of
our external backbone,
so this is the
backbone that connects
the different data
centers together, to run,
not on traditional networking
protocols like BGP, and OSPF,
and LSPs, and all
these things, MPLS,
but on OpenFlow,
which is actually
a very cluster-ish idea of
how to control networking
where it basically takes
the same idea from cluster
computing where you say, gee,
the individual nodes shouldn't
really make decisions.
Let's have a manager,
the nodes are dumb,
they basically just a pool of
nodes, we tell them what to do.
Rather than them
trying to communicate
and figuring out what to do.
So in networking, once
you have a certain scale,
you actually want the elements,
the routers, the switches,
to be relatively dumb
because they don't really
understand what's
going worldwide.
And OpenFlow, or software
defined networking in general,
really brings that world much
closer to the software world.
So now we have a
global network that we
can control much better,
and at a much higher level,
more at the application
level if you
want more than at
the network level.
So we can worry about,
hey, here's two Gmail cells
that are talking to
each other, and not
about here's port 1234 and some
QS class, and some IP ranges,
and things that
are just brittle.
So that has helped us a lot
in really pushing the envelope
in terms of how fast we can grow
and how well we can control it.
One of the biggest
advantages, and that's really
what we've seen since the
'90s on the cluster side,
is that once you move something
to be more software controlled,
you can simulate it.
And simulation means you
can do better testing.
So one of the big reasons
why we're actually
able to switch our
global backbone
from traditional to a completely
new stack in about 15 months
was that we couldn't
do that testing it
on the real hardware
in the real world.
That would be pretty risky.
But we were able to build our
global network in software
as an emulation,
so we could play
through all kinds of
disaster scenarios.
What happens if this
thing goes down?
What if this thing
goes partially down?
What if you lose this line?
Does the software react
correctly et cetera?
So if you can do the
software testing,
really the whole unit
and integration testing,
then you have much
higher confidence
that when you actually try
it out, it will really work.
And if it doesn't
work, you explain it
in a much better way.
Once you've figured it out, you
can add it to a regression test
sweep and it won't happen again.
We won't break it again
with a new software release.
So in networking, I would say
that, really in the last 10
years, has probably
been the biggest change.
That now networks are becoming
much more Cloud friendly
if you want, or
cluster friendly,
because we can start to program
just like we could program
the nodes in a data center
or the storage elements.
And you can take
the big picture,
how you want to orchestrate
things, and automatically
translate it down into what the
network elements need to do.
And your operator doesn't
need to do that anymore.
That really is a huge change.
We're still discovering
new opportunities
of how that really percolates
through the entire stack.
And you say, over here,
I used to do it this way
but now there isn't
really a reason
to do it this way
because now I can do it
the easy way because
the network actually
understands what I want to do.
FRED SAUER: OK.
We've a lot of
innovation and research.
Jeff, I wonder if you could
talk about Google's philosophy
between research
and engineering?
How does Google make the
trade offs between two?
How do you decide
which team you work on?
JEFF DEAN: I think
one of the things
that I really like
about Google is
that we have this very
continuous, not hard boundary
between research
and engineering.
So I'm in engineering but I
work on longer term problems
sometimes, and work on shorter
term things some of the time.
Really you're not a
researcher or an engineer,
you're working on
problems that fall
on different parts
of this continuum.
The same person might move
back and forth on this
as they work on some
very long term thing
and then gradually get it
closer to being ready to deploy
to real users or whatever, then
you become a little bit more
of an engineer hat.
I think that's a
really valuable thing.
So on our team we
have a bunch of people
who are a little bit
more on the research
end of the spectrum, a bunch
of people who are a little bit
more on the engineering
end of the spectrum,
and collectively
we can do things
with complimentary skill sets.
So there's a bunch of people
with a lot of machine learning
expertise on the current
team I'm working on,
and a bunch of people with
large scale distributive systems
things.
Collectively we're doing
things that none of us
could do individually
because we just
don't have the whole set
of skills in one person.
I think that's really fun.
Because you learn
a lot about that.
You learn about
what are the trade
offs of doing machine
learning algorithms at scale.
I think that's a
really valuable thing
to keep working on
interesting problems
and learning a lot as you work.
URS HOLZLE: And We've done that
very deliberately actually.
You see that today in Cloud,
but you saw that in search
10 years ago.
When you have a problem
that is so early stage,
and you can see the
ramp that really
is going to change by
orders of magnitude,
you can't incrementally engineer
the product to a better state.
I mean yes, you do that,
of course you have to,
but at the same time you
really have to fundamentally
rethink things all
the time in order
to have a chance of actually
keeping up, and hopefully even
getting ahead
versus the problem.
So research versus
engineer, it's almost not
sensible to ask the question
how are they different.
They're really different
facets of the same thing.
If you don't really
tightly coupled
that, you're going
to have research that
is no longer
grounded in reality,
or you're going to have people
that are too much grounded
in reality who are just making
today's problem better, rather
than recognizing that tomorrow's
problem is actually very, very
different, and
requires something new,
that is a departure from
what has served you well
in the past.
So we're trying to really
blend that all the time
and give people some
freedom to do crazy things.
Because what looks crazy
today might actually
look obvious tomorrow, so
you have to balance that.
ERIC BREWER: Actually a good
example that came up today,
which is the demo that was
given this morning about doing
live migration of
a video player,
it's a demo I gave
internally about a year ago.
That idea was in academia in
2003, but to get it right,
and Google took a while, and to
convince people with something
we want to bet on,
this is how we're
going to run our
clusters, it actually
takes internal consensus, ans
solving the whole problem,
which you don't solve in
academia, it's a big problem,
it has to work
for all the cases.
Then you actually then get
people to take that actually
to product, which
is [INAUDIBLE].
FRED SAUER: So you talked
about building systems.
When you built the
InktoMi search engine,
you had to get your own gear
and get your own cage in a data
center.
You even shared
one next to Google.
ERIC BREWER: We were neighbors.
URS HOLZLE: I visited that cage.
ERIC BREWER: They
sent heat my way.
URS HOLZLE: Yeah.
Yours looked much
cleaner than ours.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC BREWER: But for the
record, modern Google cluster
look more like InktoMi clusters.
JEFF DEAN: It's true.
It's true.
We no longer bungee cord
our racks to the pipes.
FRED SAUER: That's
more than 10 years ago.
ERIC BREWER: Yes.
FRED SAUER: If you were
doing it over again today,
would you build InktoMi on
the Google Cloud platform?
ERIC BREWER: Yes.
I think that part is the
easy part of the question.
Which is any start-up
shouldn't be investing
in their own infrastructure.
It's not the core
[INAUDIBLE], it's
not fundamentally to
what you want to do.
I think the harder question,
which I think you can uniquely
answer now, is when
InktoMi got to a size
where it could afford to
build it's own data center
and have it's own machine,
should it or should it not?
That's the harder question.
Before today, the
answer would have
been InktoMi should have because
there would be significant cost
savings to do so.
But if Google is wiling to
provide virtual hardware
on the same Moore's Law cost
curve as the real hardware,
then there's no
reason to switch.
And that's actually comforting
because it's a big pain
to switch.
That's new actually, new today.
FRED SAUER: Jeff.
Maybe not quite
a final question,
but what problems are
you working on today?
Is it still Google Brain?
Is it an extension thereof?
What are the future
problems that you're
trying to solve now?
JEFF DEAN: I think
one of the things
that these neural nets
are able to do, is they're
able to take very
raw forms of data
and then automatically build
interesting, high level
abstractions of that
data and give you things
that you could learn from
that data automatically.
So unlike a lot of other
machine learning techniques
where you hand engineer
features you think
are predictive of something
you ultimately care about,
these systems can build
that automatic combination
of interesting
features and discover
what is actually interesting
is automatically.
How can we package that up
and make that easier to use
has been a question we've been
wrestling with within our group
as more teams within
Google try to use
this for their own problems.
We're making some
progress on that I think.
FRED SAUER: Eric,
What problems are
you trying to solve
right now for Google.
ERIC BREWER: That's
the funny thing.
I can't talk about it.
I've been here
two and 1/2 years,
and Urs mentioned before
that we, about two years ago,
started making transitions
to what we want to build,
a joint infrastructure for
internal use and external use.
That's what I've been
working on for two years.
You can see glimpses of
it, but frankly, the best
is still to come.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Urs, maybe final
thoughts for today?
URS HOLZLE: I think
Eric is trying
to say we're solving problems
that you don't know you have.
[LAUGHTER]
No, but actually I
think Eric's pointing
to something that's
pretty profound.
Clearly where we are
today is very cool,
and if you had asked me
10 years ago could we
ever get to this kind of scale
and have it work this way
and have it be available to
really everyone at this scale
I would've said no,
it's probably unlikely.
So to some extent really, it's
incredibly cool where we are.
It's amazing when I look at
a picture like this, the fact
that we can stamp these out,
and they work this well,
and they're cost effective,
I'm sometimes surprised myself.
But in the grand
scheme of things,
I think we shouldn't
kid ourselves
about having solved the problem.
We haven't solved
the problem at all.
In fact, were 2% in or so.
So I think the most
amazing part to me
is that I'm really
confident that if we look
back 10, or even
five years from now,
to where we are today, and the
things that we're proud of,
whether that's recognizing
cats or handling petabytes,
or something like that, we're
going to really be embarrassed
because it's so lame.
And five years, or
10 years from now,
it really will be
obvious how lame
it was even though it
seems amazing today
because we're so
early in the cycle.
We're just having,
literally in the last five
years, the different elements
coming together, actually
solving the whole availability,
partitioning, consistency.
In Spanner for example,
it's a much better solution
than we had earlier.
MapReduce, we're not actually
using MapReduce anymore
for new code.
We have a new thing that's
called Flume that actually
is an even more elegant way
of expressing these things.
But just in the last
five years, we've
had the hardware and
software pieces come together
that are a good starting
point where you can go off
into a Google Brain within a
pretty short amount of time.
But if you take that
ability, then the innovation
that happens everywhere
is based on that.
I think we will really
see an acceleration,
or an accelerated pace, of
discovery and innovation
over the next five, 10 years.
We all underestimate
how fast that will be.
We realize that five years ago
we didn't have smart phones
or whatever.
But five years from
now, the smart phones
are just going to be faster and
cheaper than they are today.
No they're not.
They're actually going to
be profoundly different.
As profoundly different
as five years ago
the T-mobile G1 was
compared to the Nexus 5.
These are not the same thing.
So the same thing is going
to be true for cloud.
So when we sit here
five years from now,
or 10 years from
now, I think we'll
have some pained smiles
if you show us videos
of this conversation today,
or of keynote this morning,
and say, yeah, I guess given
the time this was cool,
but today really, that's
what we were proud of?
So to me, that's actually
the most exciting part
about all of this.
We really are just
at the beginning.
Only 1% of the world
is in the cloud.
I think the only 1% of the
Cloud's problems are solved.
But I think 5, 10
years from now we're
going to be well into the double
digits on both of these sides,
and it's going to be a
very exciting time, for me
as a computer scientist,
and I think for everyone
as a developer to
be part of this.
This could easily be the
time where decades from now
you tell your grandchildren
or whatever, yeah, I remember.
This was a time when
we went from Stone Age
to pretty modern in computing,
in software systems,
and I was there.
Now realize how
important that was.
So I hope that five
years from now you all
agree with me on that.
But I really think we're at the
beginning of something pretty
big and something I'm more
excited about than I've
been in a long time.
FRED SAUER: Great.
Thank you for that.